there is little sign that tomorrow this
city will host its pride celebrations
no signs few posters and hardly any
rainbow flags
it's supposed to be a focal point for
fun
but for many in hungary's lgbt plus
community this is a worrying and
divisive time
prime minister victor orban has just
driven through laws to restrict what he
calls
homosexual propaganda the depiction of
lgbt plus characters in
school books or television programs his
supporters say it is a move to protect
family values it's not a human right for
lgbti activists
to be in schools it's not their right to
educate
children about their lifestyle
lifestyles are for adults to make
and they are free to make whatever
choice they want to
to choose when they are adults but when
kids are at school we need to protect
them
mr orban will hold a referendum on the
issue next year the government
has put up inflammatory posters across
the city this one reads
do you fear for your child about sexual
propaganda
emmett is a transgender teenager he says
he's
angry and uncertain i
i really hope that it's not gonna get
worse
but deeply i
i feel like i should run for my life
out of here because it will get worse
so why is all this happening now
well victor orban is facing a
parliamentary election
next year and he thinks he's at his best
when fighting
an enemy first it was migrants then the
roma now he seems to have picked on the
lgbt plus community
as his bogeyman what's more he is
getting slated by
eu leaders but mr orban's calculation is
that the more grief he gets from
brussels
the more support he'll get from
hungarian voters
the genesis of this new political battle
was probably sparked by people like dora
duro a far-right mp who publicly
destroyed a book of fairy tales
because it contained gay characters
sexuality
from the political heart of this city
there's now a growing tide of discontent
some will call it bigotry mr orban
says he's defending his nation's culture
adam parsons sky news
budapest